hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
video von ihr seht schon ich befinde
mich hier an einer stelle die ihr kennt
aber normalerweise sitze ich immer hier
da sind sich normalerweise immer jetzt
ist es allerdings so dass ich mich hier
frei bewegen kann in meinem aufnahme
zimmer das liegt daran dass ihr es
wahrscheinlich schon titel gesehen hat
und zwar werden wir heute etwas mit
dieser die dem ding hier machen das hier
ist eine brille von google das heißt wir
könnten hier aufmachen können hier ein
handy reihenklemmen und dann machen wir
sie dazu setzen uns das ding auf und
sehen wo für viele aufgegangen ist die
namen sind dann befinden wir uns auf
jeden fall in einer welt deswegen habe
ich mir schon sechs verschiedene spiele
runtergeladen und wir fangen direkt an
mit dem ersten spiel über geil ich sehe
gerne werbung in don't often ich glaube
ich gucke die falsche richtung ich gucke
irgendwelche leute ein jude du musst
dich mit jetzt hier okay was ich kann
dir ok es ist schon heftig ich war noch
nie so wirklich eine achterbahn weil ich
einfach mega höhenangst habe und jetzt
schon schmidt will hey das ist übel
heftig man also hier vor ort ist jetzt
gerade aus wie immer wenn sie runter
gehen dann wieder okay jetzt gerade
jetzt kann man gerade kurz chillen als
online jetzt ist wieder schluss
mein mann ist echt so leicht wacklig auf
den beinen wenn man hier sieht so
umdrehen also ich konnte es mir nach
hinten ohio
na sie setzte spaß sind in die neuen
jerseys ich glaube das war's jetzt ich
meine wir sind wieder in der
haltestation angekommen also mal schauen
davon ist eine person der und rwe hallo
amberg und pappenheim danke danke danke
schön alters okay das krasses grad
frostig nach oben was sollen wir hin
dass mein gott was seine abend wo mein
gott nein ich bin ich bin anders
da hat das team bei diesem spiel haben
jetzt gerade mit einem fahrstuhl nach
oben und müssen jetzt gleich irgend eine
planke lang laufen
wenn ich eine untergruppe habe ich auf
jeden fall keine beine aber ich dann auf
jeden fall
das ist krass oh mein gott alter schwede
alter der fahrstuhl fällt runter ich
mache jetzt gar nichts ich gucke einfach
nur nach vorne
das l steht für luca nein nein
ok ich glaube ich muss jetzt ein
bisschen nach vorne laufen bars und was
das kann nicht wahr sein wir drehen uns
jetzt ganz langsam zurück freunde ganz
ganz langsam wir können hier komplett
runter schauen und können sehen was hier
für unglaublich viele häuser sind also
wir müssen zurück dort in den fahrstuhl
einlaufen
das ist für mich der absolute albtraum
gerade hallo
denn läuft völlig rein soll ich mal
runter springt da deswegen nicht
funktioniert ist ja hier in den
fahrstuhl rein läuft bin ich sagen meine
damen um ein grad alter was ich dachte
ich komme auf meinem pc ist das letzte
spiel was ich jetzt vorbereitet habe ist
ein wings juni spielt das heißt die
schnalle wieder mal ein google carport
hier richtig und werde ich jetzt hier
vorne auf den start-button rückten dann
lädt das ganze nämlich und wir werden
jetzt hier diese personen rein
teleportiert und können jetzt hier unten
einfach runter fliegen
jude medical tot ich wäre tot wie
krippen hier wieder auf start sind jetzt
wieder diese personen das heißt ich muss
jetzt hier in die knie gehen und ich
darf jetzt nicht nach unten gucken
sondern muss ein bisschen nach oben also
hier einfach unten und jetzt nach oben
nach rechts hier um den berg rufen hier
unten haben noch ein geschenk hat um
luft war auch das gericht aber nicht
das heißt hier um den wir jedes geschenk
mit die entlang hier durch den urwald
durch gott ist das eco malta meine
fresse ok krass hier rum ich weiß nicht
was das hier für ein heftiger berg ist
der hier solche abzweigungen hat und so
weiter aber ich muss sagen mir wird
dezent schlecht gerade aber wir sind
gelandet und mein kopf fühlt sich
richtig an
das war es jetzt vom video meine damen
und herren ich hatte dieses google card
wort den hier schon seit langer zeit
rumliegen und wollte schon immer mal ein
video damit machen man braucht
allerdings ein kameramann dafür weil man
sich im kreis dreht und den schotter
mikrofon
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wie
gesagt habe ich sehr krasse erhöhen
respekt angst keine ahnung deswegen war
es für mich als heftig solche sachen zu
machen wie es beispielsweise dieses
wortgeplänkel dieses wingsuit mäßige
wenn es euch gefallen hat und ihr wette
vorschläge für via games hat eventuell
horror spieler oder so schreiben es
gerne in die kommentare lasten like da
und jetzt ist ein video vorbei